Let's get to writing some code. Now, in the Python RE module, there are two functions: search and match.
Search takes a pattern, a regular expression in the form of a string as we've defined, and a text,
and it returns "true" if the pattern appears anywhere in the text.
Rather, I should say I'm simplifying a little bit here.
The Python RE module returns a more complicated result, a not literally true, but a result that is true and has some more data.
But in our implementation we're just going to return "true" or "false."
So if the pattern occurs anywhere in the text, return "true",
and then "match" says "return true if the pattern appears at the very start of the text."
To make sure we understand what these are supposed to be returning, let's add some tests.
Here we had four tests, each testing this regular expression, "baa*!"
If we search for that within the string, "Sheep said baaaa!" it should find it right here.
If we search within this string, it shouldn't find it because the B and the As are there,
but it's not followed by an exclamation point, so that should be false.
If we try to match it against this string, it's false because it doesn't occur right at the start.
And if we try to match it against this string, it's true because there is a match right at the start.
Now, regular expressions are complicated, so I wanted to add some more tests.
Just to go through, we'll check for the dollar sign, we'll check for the up arrow at the start.
We'll check for stars, we'll check for the question mark, optional, and we'll go into more detail,
testing a pattern against multiple possible words--at the end, at the start, in the middle, check for this dot character.
And if we can do all that, then we have some confidence that our routines are working.
So let's get back to the routines.
Now, if you want, you could go ahead and try to write search and match.
They're complicated, and you need to understand a little bit about the processing of regular expressions to get them right.
If you feel you're up to it, go ahead and try it now.
If not, I'm going to lead you through it step by step.
The two seem similar, so it'd be nice to write one in terms of each other.
Let's write "search" in terms of match, although it'd be possible to do it the other way around.
Now, a real distinction is whether a pattern starts with a up arrow or not.
So if we're searching, remember, a search tests against anywhere in the pattern.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to check, say, "Does the pattern start with the up arrow?"
And the only place that the up arrow really makes sense is as the first character in the pattern.
If it appears elsewhere, we're gonna just consider that an error and not try to deal with it.
Your program can return whatever you want if the up arrow appears in the wrong place, not right at the start of the pattern.
If it does return right at the start of the pattern, then we can reduce this to a match with some different pattern over the same text.
And if it doesn't, then we can also return it to a match, reduce it to a match with some different pattern over the text.
What I'd like you to do is fill in these two patterns to say,
"What is a search expressed at in terms of a match with an up arrow and without an up arrow?"